here is Ron desantis's advice for Gavin
Newsom with all those problems he has a
real serious fixation on the State of
Florida I mean I think it's just bizarre
that he does that but what I would tell
what I would tell him is you know what
stop pussy-footing around are you gonna
are you gonna throw your hat in the ring
and challenge uh Joe are you gonna get
in and do it or are you just going to
sit on the sidelines and Chirp so why
don't you throw your hat in the ring and
then we'll go ahead and talk about what
what's happening so good line glad to
see that DeSantis is attacking Gavin
Newsom but of course there is no reason
for Gavin Newsom to throw his hat in the
ring right now Gavin Newsom is not
traveling all around the country
attacking Ron DeSantis building a
national base from building the
beginnings of a campaign in order to
convince voters to vote for him over Joe
Biden that is not how the Democrat Party
Works